hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to factorio it works my
god [ __ ] work Oh
so let me explain everything here the
inner loops better than mine yeah let's
just do it
let's do a quick comparison between the
two just mmm hey I just got some science
out of there there's some science going
on yeah there's some science even though
it's totally clogged right now I can't
do anything but it's fine okay so the
basis of this is the idea that the the
outer loop is entirely based on making
science that's the only thing is for
except for the connect the conveyor
system it needs an input but it gets
input from an outside source and then
the gears are placed on the inner loop
now this actually I'm actually going to
expand this because this can make more
this can do more this can make more
science than this because there's an
abundance of material on the outside of
the loop so I'm gonna get more copper
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] the lag is still a little
bit weird like I don't know why the lags
happening cuz we switch now I'm hosting
the game but for some reason there's
still some weird luck but I'm gonna I'm
gonna live with it because this is so
cool it's so cool
I got damnit I keep going into the woods
when I want to stop okay so I just need
some more iron and copper and then I'm
going to make more assembly machines and
then put them on the outside loop on the
bottom side because there's plenty of
space down there I can I can actually
expand the loop out a bit more and then
we will have glorious glorious capacity
we will have so much science being
produced now what had many capacities
yeah but now I know there's a science
pack three in a science pack four and I
don't even want to know what the
assembly loops gonna look like that son
of a [ __ ] like my god I'm sure it will
be just as efficiently bill wait a
minute that's not right why is the
inside why is the inside clogged up with
uh with uh what's he get side clogged up
shouldn't be clogged up what's inside
clients I mean like I know it's just
clogged up with gears
oh that's right because I needed an
output filter of gears I I needed that
one last thing for this is the overflow
because gears always overflow there's
always like too many of them so after
all of the production need that needs
gears grabs gears I have a smart filter
filter out gears so that any excess
gears gets put in a box oh so you just
need another smart grabber on the
outside filtering out the gears no no
inside inside the inside line is only
dedicated to gears so it's fine that
that gears full ideally the inner loop
would also have gears only being placed
on the inside and but that that'd be
really freaking hard to do oh I just had
a brainwave what's this thing yeah wait
ah do that thing you just thought of I I
could have these two up here instead of
these both dedicating to the outside
loop I could have them both where I'm
standing and then one puts it on the
outside loop and one puts it on the
inside loop cuz know if yeah if I moved
one down then I could put the gears on
the inside of the inside loop where
nothing is currently because it's out of
materials why why is the outside of the
outside loop ballgame DUP ah because it
needs more science production that's
what that's what I was about to do so on
this bottom line I'm literally gonna put
down way more science doodads
so what's also and it only needs it
doesn't need both of these transporter
things so you could set this one to
science do then uh it's what that's what
that means right true but let me put
these down to see if we can get enough
here because we may have prematurely
celebrated the whole it works something
like yeah totally works
no let's look into it I work always
standing exactly where I want to put
something okay there we go I just I'll
just continuously move around so at
least I'll own it anyway for a brief
moment but then you just end up being
everywhere in my way and I can't
possibly get anything done okay so if
these are all science these are all
science these are all science
okay cool good job Bob good job Eagle up
you have he'll hit it yes master
the little six - OH
Nikes I just shipped clicked on the
manufacturing tab and made 73 haha good
enough that's good enough for anybody
okay so all right I got all your oh you
got all your inserters already yeah I'm
trying to make it symmetrical so don't
even touch anything it's gonna be
beautiful I can look up Bob no no I did
it damn it Bob you did it perfectly
I can't even create it you did it good
job exactly what your brain wanted thank
you Bob
you are a goddamn genius well okay bye
let's have the best well okay um don't
don't take this away from me
I wasn't I earned this you earned this
good job Bob you earned it
okay so what I'm gonna do is also have
that do that and put an extra extractor
over here cuz ha science hell outta da
da da da dadada no no don't fit my no no
no lag okay there we go okay so all
right so this is good
like good call on only one transporter
belt production because that's important
and now the outside loop is getting fed
with plenty of is there anything choking
up these know they're getting plenty of
what they need it's yeah everything's
cool
that's so balanced I just need to
replace this with a fast one and
everything is good I just got a lot of
science backs nice how many I have a
hundred and six in my inventory right
now okay anyway
okay Wicked Witch of the mark all right
I may have gotten overly ambitious on
making all these science things I'm in
fact I'm a hundred percent certain that
I went oh
or Don making all these citations it
seems like it'll be fine science takes a
long time to produce it does you're
right but I don't think it's like I
don't think for inserter creators is
gonna be enough to make everything but
it's cool why is it low on gears we not
need to get the inner part is low on
gears huh apparently I didn't even
realize that was possible oh okay just
sticks to finish now we can replace all
of these transporter belts with fast
transporter belts yay we did it haha now
I like to celebrate oh yeah I'm just
like the science officer oh sorry
I'll do all the research oh it's so nice
well I mean I can't be trusted with
actually thinking because you saw how
much brain power is dedicated just to
making this work
it barely is limping along but it beauty
is doing it oh man we just need a lot we
need a lot more insert or production
it's a bit slow on the inserter
production but if it could go faster
hopefully would just go faster you
inserter [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] [ __ ] a bit Beach and honestly
the only oh the gears on the outside are
out of iron already awesome yeah we need
a lot more iron production which means
that we need to change those burners up
top to steel furnaces I can actually
make those I'll make the steel furnaces
cuz that I've got a lot of steel so you
need steel I've got like oh no no no no
no no no no I got lots of steel worry
about steel let me worry about steel oh
I actually have seven stacks of steel so
it's missile of steel well look at you
they just steel furnaces go faster they
go twice as fast they go twice as fast
sexy so basically now there shouldn't be
a choke hold of all this iron so now I
can put some more iron particulars up in
here her jig udders yeah exactly that's
the technical term on there and yeah
[ __ ] iron for though you got tell me
about particulars I I know about
projectors I actually know nothing about
kerja Gators so if you could explain
that scientifically speaking exactly
what we're talking about here because
also okay when you need something out of
the what's it called it's important they
get the right type of critter
okay sleep alright one knows that uh uh
and uh and yeah so over here I looked
and I was like well it's ironing it to
the ground so I it's it's these
particular kind of contributors right
here oh yeah I spin and they move back
and forth yeah I see that
crucial for iron production okay goodra
sure of course yeah I mean I should have
known that but obviously you know but
what I do everyone knows that mark okay
I I didn't at the moment but now I do so
thank you for everyone knows that yeah
professor Bob everyone knows that PhD
why do you have to smart filters
filtering out the science because there
was a lot of science going on and
couldn't handle it there's not as much
science now yeah I know it was it was
just a short-term solution to a not a
problem it busted it out because it was
so backed up with all the inserter 'z
that was making us is barely keeping up
with inserter production wait why sleep
oh it's out of metal again so maybe our
next what if our next strategy is we
should get either set up iron production
to the south is there iron to the south
yeah maybe take advantage of this iron
production and uh is there coal down
here probably not huh there's a lot of
iron there is not a lot of anything else
maybe we should set up that iron
production to the north with some fast
conveyer belts and get some iron plates
feeding down here automatically that
would be super cool I like that thinking
that is radical and I'm not the best at
designing things to go in directions but
you know I can try you can try yeah I
see I think you could do well I think
you could do really well I think you've
got a lot of potential I really if I
really put my mind to it yeah I think I
think that's actually not a bad idea
because that means that we'll have more
than enough all right so I'm gonna sort
of just freeform this is that good
strategy yeah usually whenever you're
going after things are scientific and
important wait where did you even go
word Bob oh there you are you like
blended in here
hi Bob hey buddy hi
okay so ah
and then we commit yeah underground
underground yeah I got it
I got it bro don't you worry about blank
let me worry love like I get that
refugee D I understand it it's a good
reference
hey so now that can feed down and we can
get long handles to do the dirty work
ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] would [ __ ] rob
would [ __ ] you douche bag
sorry KK KK KK KK kick yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Oh actually just just to make it nice
underground underneath our Road for no
reason but I mean that we could put more
Road shut up mark the room look how nice
it looks look how nice it looks it's
okay just let me have this one I'm sorry
I'm sorry Bob I'll never question your
decisions again Eugene right so now I
have to actually think about we need
iron here here and over to the left by
those long handles is there any other
iron feeds that we need yeah there's an
iron feed but it's impossible to get to
because on the inside bro-bro
underground bro you're under glass whoa
sorry Bob again with me I'm just so
stupid I can't do anything right even
got a heron's didn't want me it's gotta
have faith man okay gotta have gotta
have faith okay I got this don't you
even where our it doesn't go that far
nevermind hang on I'm still working it
out like I probably got this no problem
I I believe in you a hundred percent Bob
you are the kingpin of every design
choice in this world and or the wind
beneath my wings mark thank yes backing
me up on this one i and honestly I love
you is like I just wanted to clear that
out loud just because you know haven't
had a chance to say it properly so just
you know know that I feel in my heart a
lot of love I I feel it don't you worry
about that I feel it you know what's
really gonna put the icing on the cake
here is when I make this a complete loop
so that it feeds itself like an
unbelievable boss
[ __ ] I'm just adding a little more umph
tier to your metal so hang on cuz we
gotta bundles a noodles noodles or think
about these things I can do this okay
III do this Bob are you are you saying I
should doubt your ability no no I got
this I'm so unquestioning on everything
that you were doing that at this point I
I don't know oh you know what
no that's not gonna work just to make it
easier I'm gonna take this last one out
of here cuz I would actually well that
would make it are you taking that whole
okay oh yeah I'm not taking the whole
line I'm just taking that you look at
you you just made my whole life yeah
everything makes sense again haha yeah
mark I knew you were here for some
reason
Oh things I just want to mean something
to you Bob
I just want to mean something oh no I'm
out of amount of roads oh I got it you
want me to finish it up uh you you do
whatever you want buddy okay I'm gonna
use a combination of underground and
normal ground oh go for it it's gonna be
sexy
cuz there's this electrical pole in a
way and I can't I can't get rid of that
so I know you know that needs to be
there that was very carefully put there
I gotta go it has to be R ground yeah oh
[ __ ]
actually I mean oh [ __ ] we need some
copper on this too don't we hahaha wait
hey the coppers right here man wait ah
right [ __ ] here man is it
I can't bring copper over here no
problem man no problem man no problem at
all man man man okay that's good Oh
works it's so pretty and symmetrical
it's so it's so horrifying beautiful and
looks amazing
okay alright oh god just are you are you
making fun of me as oh no I just can't
believe that I did that I made that
happen it's likely is unbelievable [ __ ]
but it
it's not the ugliest thing in the world
it's not the ugliest thing I've ever
seen it's actually pretty acceptable I'm
okay with that extra you put extra hand
grabbers over here what are you doing to
me
wine we needed more iron it wasn't
enough to feed everything get him oh
come on man don't be like that
yeah you took my victory also if you get
that reference I do my best friends for
a reason oh there is one grabber here
that is just doing a dance it's
literally it's literally freaking learn
are you on the inside loop by the gears
it is freaking the [ __ ] out like it's
gonna grab one and then just Reggie
Reggie Reggie we talked about this I
think it's time for you to retire man oh
man I don't think you moving as fast as
you used to move I don't there we go I
gotta fight for your family but come on
uh-uh it's just you're you're well past
retirement age Reggie like this is
getting embarrassing like you're a
liability at the workplace now I just
need to get one more way on I got it
all right just don't wash me you're
making me nervous
am i doing this for 30 years yeah he
thought I wouldn't notice like he'd be
safe on the inside away from everything
else but I noticed Reggie we got our
eyes on you whoo okay anyway that's all
the time we got for this episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you Bob check out Bob sale in the
link in the description below and as
always we'll see
ba-bye dancer which a one-ball lily
wacker baby probably thought my middle
name was a people year and that was
where I got markiplier come from no it's
much stupider than that